coming up next it's not easy for a guy
to be swayed like that I think it takes
a bit more than just honoring the guy
find out about the girls he hasn't
married don't repeat the mistakes they
made
that would be useful don't be a pushover
when he's trying to make a date that's
terrible that's the worst advice that's
terrible advice don't discuss your
former boyfriends yeah
you don't have any if he's Rich tell him
you like his money the honesty will
Intrigue him Matt no
what do you guys think so the guys that
had so you two and who was the next
longest after seven years
oh five seven five did you say three
months of the year are you two said
three yes okay what do you guys think of
the phrase Mary before you carry do you
think that's for you two especially do
you think that's true yes you can marry
before you carry 100
I mean I have a kid now so I don't feel
like I could answer that question
oh you can still answer it if you could
go back to me me obviously in in the
same position I have a I have a
five-year-old daughter
however I fully believe in that though I
fully believe that's like though that's
like the right way right I think that if
I'm gonna say oh just because I didn't
do it
I'll be I'll be I'll be lying you know
what I mean so there's a level
accountability we've got to have with
that situation and and for me that would
110 be be the ideal and it's like what I
said before
I wouldn't marry without the intention
to have a child yeah so when I do the
only way that I will be having my next
child
would be following marriage and and
that's a hundred and ten percent
um a bit so how old are you now 128 now
so you're 28 so you meet a girl tomorrow
let's say you're the same age you
wouldn't have a kid with her until she's
32.
it's wild yeah no it's just interesting
because I really understand where the
guys are coming from but it's like the
one thing that we kind of have
conflicting is like marriage is a bad
contract but we want people to be
married to have kids so how do you
reconcile that
I think he's uh so we have we I think we
all have our guidelines but there's a
level of like communication that you've
got that you've got to have right I
think that's like that's like the key
thing to it because obviously the female
body's changing the exit exit what is it
after is it after 30 they start dropping
I think 90 of your eggs are gone by age
30. yeah but I think there are a lot of
why I think sometimes men end up you
know like choosing wrong even though
that's hard I know women are crazy but I
think that it's just so hard for you
guys to get women that like the first
nice girl that comes along is like yeah
I'll have sex with you for the rest of
my life you're like okay I will wipe her
up and I think that's how a lot of guys
get stuck because they're not looking at
like character because if you think
about like what the standard that most
men have for relationships it's like you
know is she nice is she pretty does she
stick around like yeah I could see how
you know she ends up like taking you for
half because you know she she could be
off right that's why you need to have
these long periods where you need to
understand like like my mom I'm saying
about a year and all stuff it's that's
the whole point of that to make sure
that doesn't happen and the longest the
longer time you do it
um the more sort of tests you put
through then it will limit minimal your
risk of being in a situation and also
it's the fact that some guys just don't
have a lot of options and they don't
think they can get better so they focus
on this one person of who like you say
do you know what as well yeah I think
this is gonna as men
a year wasted is not that bad yeah and
this is not this is not even to sound
crazy but okay say a man's 29 yeah and
he meets a woman at 29 they get into a
relationship the relationship doesn't
work
the way the woman is looking at the
world at 30 and the same the way the man
is looking at the world at 30 is not the
same yeah so you could always bounce
back and I think with men are kind of
scared to get it wrong
it makes sense because it's such a bad
contract for men so it just sounds like
most men are willing to take the risk
even though there's nothing in it for
them really nowadays if the girl puts in
the time
as much as as like the woman in me is
like wow that's so much time I
understand it it almost seems like it
makes the deal more fair even though
it's unfair for men it goes back to our
argument that we feel we think logically
we think how can we minimize the risk
yeah because it's a safe bet is this
okay whatever the worst gonna happen how
much is this gonna damage me and a man
at 30 35 years old as we go up our money
gets more you know we get more handsome
our beards grow more you know stuff like
that so there's more there's more stuff
for us and of course as you go up your
options actually expand a lot so you
want to make sure you're right making
the right choice um can I ask you guys a
question you know how women aren't
really taught to be wives right now uh
do you think that men are taught how to
find a wife identify a wife no
no no I don't think there's a teaching
but I think we all have like different
forms of like Role Models around us so
the females around us that example I've
got a like my sister she she got married
then had had her children bought a house
with her husband and and and and my mum
same scenario I think we we all whether
it's our family or family friends we see
and we we know really what we should be
going for because I think I think you
like literally have to sit down and talk
about this stuff I think that's like you
know reasons for the churches although
it's not it's not the best you know
statistics for marriage either but they
literally sit down and say like Hey by
scripture this is what a wife looks like
but I think that's how men are getting
Bamboozled it's like nobody like
literally sits you down I was like okay
this is what a virtuous woman looks like
I think the fatherless homes I think are
contributing to that because I think
your dad is supposed to teach you
because your mom will lie to you you
know but I think your dad will tell you
yeah there's identifiers and men look
for them all the time but the thing is
women aren't actually told what those
identifiers are until much later on and
also I actually think the solution is a
woman should actually start looking for
something serious a lot younger instead
of using her younger years to like test
the playing field or like go on dates
and stuff when she turns 18 I think she
should actually start considering
looking for something serious in L.A I
just think at the end of the day like
women are a roll of the dice I I
genuinely think like
you're just never gonna know for sure
and it's just it's just a risk but like
I understand with how bad the contract
is today like why they want to take so
much time seven years if you laugh for
me that's a bit too yeah seven years is
mud I'll be honest but the problem is as
well though I think obviously you always
mention that and if people always
mention taking half taking half taking
half we like we hear about it like a lot
and the kids and and obviously like the
kids in that situation but one thing is
a lot a lot of men have the fear of odd
woman's gonna take half I reckon about
half the men there's nothing for the
woman to even take half of so that's the
first number no that's the that's the
realness though because if we really
look at it and everybody has there's a
trial balance
um and we're looking at what's really
there first and foremost there's not a
lot so one thing I'd I'll cut like from
my personal situation my daughter's
favorite
so I think yeah when I was 21.
so the first thing was like right I've
had her out of marriage so my first
thing was security what's the first
thing so I was thinking right what can I
do what can I do so for me it was about
securing a um but her security was to
get a property so then I was thinking
okay cool but now if I marry that's
already pre-marriage so as long as you
sign it then obviously whatever you have
as a marriage going forward then I split
that's what I think it's fair that's why
I could never be with someone that that
obviously the theme I'm not working for
me that's not really I need especially
nowadays she needs to be earning like a
like a 30k year 40K year just just to
keep things ticking because that's
expensive now Joe I mean so I think yeah
we need to be put too much and we put
too much emphasis sometimes on the whole
taking taken I actually think that
taking half and this is probably
unpopular I think it's worse for the
average guy than it is for Rich guys
because like I think of I think of my
dad if my mom took halfway he'd be fine
even if he had like maybe she took 80 of
his wealth like he's so productive that
he would just make more more and like
maybe not as much but he would be fine
but I think like the average guy takes
him 25 years to get to that point and
then she can also take half also on that
point if
if
um
I I let's say I had a wife we had we had
two kids uh a girl and a boy and for
whatever reason she wanted to get a
divorce
I I would I would want them to have half
maybe even three quarters I'm good I'm
all right like I'm gonna be good I just
I need what I need and I'm gonna be good
and I can get out there I can still do
whatever I would want them to have most
because not not for not necessarily for
my partner
but for my kids for sure I would want
them to have all of that well if she
takes the kids and doesn't let you see
them oh no no no that's not that's
impossible
she's paid to do it do you have kids my
brother no no kids no so that's why you
say that that's why it answers that but
yeah okay but I hear
what is it there I forgot the person
that mad billionaire his wife got half
that's the one I didn't know if you
could do name drops I thought I'd make
it big yeah but um yeah we've got half
but the situation and the point where
they got married the financial situation
was not that I feel like genuine I feel
that she was due that the problem is
it's like no but no but that's what
because we're talking about all these
things like loyalty and we're looking at
all of these lists and at the end of the
day she would have played a a role to to
enable him to do that
but look at their wealth after the
marriage if she played that big of a
role she would have made more money
after they got married where he his his
wealth increased by like fifty percent
like I just think like there's a
difference between like your wife doing
your accounting versus really building
your business no no 100 and 10 I think
yeah that's that's fact but
obviously the reason she got such a big
chunk was because at the point of
marriage to at the point of divorce I'm
sure there was like sporadic growth and
we can't there's all of these things
here she would really have had to
build up her man if she was the type of
person that all she was doing at home
was always testing build up a minute
you can inspire a man but I just I I
grew up around like Ultra Ultra
successful man they were going to be
successful whether or not they had a
girl there but earlier on we was talking
about testing now I in my opinion I
don't think Jeff Bezos would have built
that massive if all if worst was at home
always testing testing testing like I
just it's possible Right but I feel that
maybe not a huge role that she would
have played her part in that and in and
she was she was looked after for that
yeah it was a ridiculous amount of money
it was a ridiculous amount she just got
divorced again from a school teacher
yeah but you know so okay I have a
question for everyone who raised your
hand do you think if a girl's with you
for 20 years she deserves half
I'm gonna do different percentages so
you say half you say up 20 years half
okay do you think she deserves
um 30 percent
of your wealth
off to 20 years and the people that
didn't say 50. 30 because she deserved
20 20. 20 you give her 20. all right ten
percent
does anyone think zero percent
okay
does anyone think more than 50 percent
okay I just I'm just curious my
perspective is a little bit different I
mean like I am I am married I didn't
raise my hand
I can't imagine I mean this is my
perspective so it's very subjective
um so I can't imagine any reason that I
would get divorced I think it would have
to come down to something that's
absolutely uncontrollable like there's
nothing that I could think about at this
point in time you know maybe maybe
there's uh an addiction or maybe you
know there could be the death of a child
sometimes you just can't come back for
that but my thing about it is like if I
had to had to outside of my control get
divorced I feel like I could sit down
over breakfast and have a conversation
because the intent is that you don't
marry you know like an a-hole right you
sit down and you say look I don't think
this relationship is viable uh can I get
your help for the next three to six
months how much do you think you could
do this is when I expect I can get a job
I feel like you can negotiate I think
women are too too quick to go to the
court over things that you can really
settle down over breakfast but I I think
it's the women typically that don't want
to be the an adult in that situation and
I think that that's wrong yeah I think
if she spent a certain amount of time
with you and she's invested in you in
your growth now that might not be like
you mentioned about the Jeff Bezos thing
he had nothing really until he didn't
have what when he married her he didn't
have nothing to a certain degree to what
he's got now right so she's she's
factored into that to some degree of
success now that might not be from a
business aspect but it's from some of
the things we've mentioned here today on
the board you know peace support etc etc
and I feel like that is not a reward but
almost like a a uh like maybe a payout
or just like a compensation to some
degree but she has to but this is this
goes back to our point before of like
this is why we spend a lot of time
vetting them to even get the ring in the
first place because you want to feel
like okay she's built me up to a certain
way where she yeah I wouldn't feel too
bad about giving her half because she's
been there from the from the bottom and
I'm like I'm a huge believer in whatever
you have before marriage that's your
that's his that's hers I agree that's
what I believe but whatever is after the
marriage like a decent and split but
whatever's before the marriage is is
fully separate so whatever happens
beyond that I think it's the first split
all right um Rose of hands do you think
men should page do you think men should
pay child support
yes yes if you think yes it depends on
the context so if I know all the money
is going to the children yeah okay so oh
interesting so you yeah you mentioned so
100 100 of men okay interesting but is
that what you're saying just there if I
know if it's going to I don't know then
I'm paying for child myself yeah I will
pay the child myself
a bit about the child I think women are
so so so dumb sometimes because like
let's say you had you had a cool baby
daddy right you guys were chilling
co-parenting whatever and then you got
this little little bug in your ear
talking about taking taking the child
support put him on child support
you know like that man might be offended
and give you less and he was already
going to be involved in the child
because he wants that kid but now you as
the woman you're gonna get 300 or 500 a
month you're stupid you could have been
getting like a couple Grand or if you
stayed in the relationship you could
have been getting all the resources but
uh yeah uh the married woman did not
raise her hand no child support for me
no yeah I just I just don't know why
we're paying girls to leave yeah like
that that's that's my my like that's the
way I think about it I'm like where why
does she get money I didn't get pregnant
yeah no money
I hear it it's not taking away
accountability but I think guys have
this innate like protection almost
towards women so I just think it's kind
of in guys
I'd be more thinking about the kids yeah
you know I think we solve the child
support
um problem men should just get custody
of the children yeah and that's how many
of you think that you think men should
automatically get custody of the
children I mean
statistics
depends on the age okay
hmm okay because they actually improved
yeah statistically like they'll keep the
sun's out of jail on there definitely
the girls their daughter's off the
stripper pole I think there's a time for
mum and then there's a age for that why
do you say no
um I say no because I would imagine I'd
pick a good woman to look after my child
and I'd still be involved so my
involvement is gonna steer them in the
right direction so okay I'm gonna Read
Super chats because I haven't read them
in the show
sorry guys I see you guys blowing up the
chat guys make sure you like the video
um the like is the most important metric
that YouTube uses there's almost 2 000
people in here so there should be 2 000
likes on the video make sure you hit
that like button okay
um Swiss um if she's not an asset she's
a burden um Philip holy mackerel Pearl
and Ally back together again let's go
KCF have you guys noticed how peaceful
and civilized Today's Show is when it's
a bunch of logical minded guys and
there's no emotional 304 is just saying
a 200 super chatter
um
Tyler Tyler zuka I'm choosing choosing a
month total for specific relationship
Milestones as a Fool's errand chemistry
and commitment is all that matter
waiting to have sex before marriage no
no corn no Fab is the only way to show
someone you are serious about the
marriage else you are just exploiting
each other from the start uh Matt
butcher it's all often the women who
have totally unreal expectations and or
trying to change the man after the fact
or they are just evil to begin with
Mr Dill agaf if a marriage breaks up and
the judge grants 50 50 to custody then
there shouldn't be any child support
payment if the marriage laws didn't
punish men women wouldn't break up a
marriage Dario Duplin I know I'm late
but my older brother took seven years
before he married his wife they've been
together for 15 years now Tales from um
settled Ranch and engagement time
shouldn't be infinite since no man in
the U.S should marry it exposes you to
the worst emotional and financial
disaster possible Meg Tao Doug MPA
feminism made it so men don't owe women
anything a man can take as long as he
wants to commit it's up to the woman to
leave if he's taking too long Matt
butcher a lady can easily put on an act
for six months to hook you when you
found out how psycho she is you will be
floored um amend Dana it if it takes
knowing all women to figure them out you
never will learn the one person you're
with and learn them just saying iconic
FPS men want someone to support them
would it not be relevant to lead by
example and remain monogamous for the
sake of leading by example Matt butcher
the multiple partners thing gets old and
is a lot to keep up with the best is one
partner and the best is one partner and
know how to get her to want sex Pearl
did you have trouble reading this LOL
shut up
um TJ Drummond 178 100 Super Chat thank
you Reginald Enterprises it's always the
top men but it was Men in your town now
that travel is easy it's it's become the
top men in the world 90 Frito pie
be righteous about saying no to sex
don't be Petty Matt Hugh I love your
message you're making change in here
healing the world speak we are listening
see Dumbledore if um guys either after
the wedding or after the first kid comes
it's all over dead bedroom is
practically guaranteed uh Russ Kristen H
I had all of that at one point I lost
her to the pursuit of a career 93 topai
employees get to test because they won't
submit employees get to test because
they submit they trust each other women
hold the hostage to prove a point four
panel the last compliment four panel the
last compliment you've gotten
Rob Harmony
women should not Shack with a man she
doesn't respect if she doesn't respect
him she should be able to trust the
decision he makes as a man not trusting
a man as an excuse for a poor
decision-making in women
um which cat bore I can't say that name
Pearl should be using the white more
more often
I'm not
I don't want to read that one Christian
h no friends no social media stop
laughing blessings
um no no friends no social media same
religion smaller than myself by at least
50 to 40 percent fit motherly cute not
cute not hot Frugal girly loyal
respectful in public last but not least
less than three bodies a million dollar
girl Alistar Horton my answer peace
common goals support brutal honesty a
rational mind so you can make decisions
in my absence reducing my workload at
home and a second opinion when necessary
and comforting see Dumbledore can we
please stop saying I can only speak for
me unless you're an ambassador or
Minister it's a given that you're only
speaking for yourself Jason ghost um
start the collection play at the church
is it the church is in service fiber
keep up the great content and thank you
for giving voice to discussions that are
ignored Okay so
so going with the topic what should
women bring to the table
I'm going to read some advice from the
19 I think it's 20s or 30s
um and we're going to see if you guys
think this is good advice
how to land him so how to get how to get
you a man
show and show him you can have fun on a
cheap date but don't overdo it
yeah yes 100 yeah okay don't let your
parents treat him like a treat to him
like a potential husband
um what what I'm just reading I'm this
is ask your parents to disappear when
you're entertaining double date with a
gay happily married couple let him see
what it's like
um
hell no tell his friends nice things
about him
yeah yeah hype your man up um send his
mother a birthday card yes ask his
mother for her recipes yes definitely
talk to his father about business and
agree that taxes are too long okay you
know what that sounds like a great Pro
tip actually
the taxes aren't you yeah that's funny
that's funny by his sister's children an
occasional present yes yeah do that on a
first date tell him you aren't thinking
of getting married
oh okay so he doesn't feel the pressure
that's a weird advice for the 1920s or
30s
I'm just saying good advice or bad
advice bad it should be between no I
think it's good a first date talking
about will you marry me like maybe the
third one don't talk about how many
children you want
to see what's wrong no that's actually
quite important okay if he's a fisherman
learn to skill and clean fish yes yes oh
that's interesting don't don't tell him
everything about yourself at the start
hold something in reserve yes yeah when
you're out strolling with him don't
insist on stopping at every shop window
yes please I disagree please
don't tell him how much your clothes
cost
yes learn to sew learn to sew oh I'm
interested because 22-22 learn to sew
and wear something you've made yourself
yes
a lot yes learn to solve I want to see
Patrick sewn into my trousers don't
gossip about him
oh this is interesting never let him
know he's the only one even if you have
to stay home one or two nights a week
what the hell well this is why you're
recording right yeah yeah what do you
guys think no no
definitely need to know if I don't know
I am not doing anything serious
that's the worst thing I've ever had in
my life well I think back then maybe
they weren't sleeping with more than one
person no no yeah yeah there's a
difference then they weren't sleeping
with anyone else yeah you could go on
multiple dates with men without sleeping
with them and I think like women should
do that but they don't but they don't
they'll bang on the first day so it's
like if a woman makes a guy think that
he's not the only one he'll run away she
will decide that she will never be she's
joining the broadcast Recreation don't
um don't be a pushover when he's trying
to make a date
that's terrible
that's terrible advice all right very
early in your dating why not get a
favorite song that you both regard as
your own as I start to like it's like
your song that's cute yeah it's like a
shoe collection find out about the oh
this is actually good advice find out
about the girls he hasn't married don't
repeat the mistakes they made
that would be useful don't discuss your
former boyfriends yeah
yes don't have any if you are widowed or
divorced don't constantly discuss your
former husband same thing be flexible if
you just got if he decides to skip the
dance and go rowing on the lake go even
if you were wearing your best evening
gown yeah I agree with that have fun yep
hi hide your Phi Beta Kappa key if you
own one later on Junior later on Junior
can play with it what's up so it's a
sorority key what does that mean what is
that that's a U.S one I don't know turn
wolves into husband material by assuming
they have honor
turn wolves oh so you're saying like
turn the bad boy into a husband but like
basically assuming he has honor so like
treating him I assume the best in him
yeah yeah yeah yeah I think it's
possible yeah why do you hesitating I
don't know it's just like the it's not
easy for a guy to be swayed like that I
think it takes a bit more than just
honoring the guy
because when you when you do that to a
guy who's not in a position to want to
when you do that to a bad guy a wolf in
that case you just get you're just
leaving yourself open to be taken
advantage of in my opinion you know how
they say you can't turn a hole into a
housewife why are you trying to turn a
bad boy into a house exactly he will do
it on his own time when he's ready women
think they can fix men in that regard
yeah you can't listen listen by the way
the the the the advice was saying the
woman should assume he has honor and
will switch up his ways to for the right
word oh yes oh yeah it's a it's a mental
thing they're saying like don't assume
he's like don't assume he's a wolf or
else that's what you're gonna see and I
think this is possible yeah that that's
definitely possible yeah I know guys who
would change up entirely if they met the
right girl tomorrow so that's that's
definitely the case learn where to draw
the line but do it gracefully um yes
remain Innocent but not ignorant yeah oh
my God these are amazing make your home
comfortable when he calls large ashtrays
comfortable chairs
learn learn to play poker machine
man if he's Rich tell him you like his
money the honesty will Intrigue him Matt
nah
I think that that's like I don't think
there's nothing I don't feel there's
nothing wrong with that like woman uh no
because women women are hard wired women
are hard-wired I expect men to provide
so she's attracted to a man that's rich
yeah but I like your money I don't think
a man's trying to hear it you'll leave
if he loses the money no no I don't
think it's like that like men don't want
to feel like they're going to work for
nothing no no because you could be like
babe thank you so much for going to work
I really appreciate what you're
contributing to the household it means
the world to me you know like let him
know that you like that he's gainfully
employed
if it said you didn't meant if it said
tell him you like his money but say it
gracefully
you're telling him but listen I love how
much money
I love the house okay whatever what
about you what about you're such a
hard-working man oh yeah the thing is by
saying it by saying it like that you're
respecting his work ethic Yeah by saying
it like that I like your bread and it's
nice that's not what he's trying to
that's not what that's not what he's
trying to hear no no never let him
believe oh this is never let him believe
your career is more important to you
than marriage yes yes
buy or buy him an amusing or
particularly appropriate present every
once in a while but don't make it too
expensive yes
I like cheap funny gifts clip and mail
him a funny cartoon that means something
to both of you and don't tell dirty
stories
full gift I think yeah I think that's
the point is do do something even if
it's free to let them know you thought
of him
um stop being a mama's girl don't let
him think he'll have trouble with his
mother don't think let him think he'll
have in-law trouble even if you know he
will
oh this one is so funny this last one is
so funny okay
point
out to him that the death rate of single
men is twice that of married man
what do we think all these Goods so far
more hits a few misses okay I have one
more article I was going to read and
then today's women I'll tell you I feel
like the first I feel like the first
half sounded like it come from a place a
lot of things come from a place of
respect I found out I mean it got a bit
left after but I feel definitely feel
like the first batch was definitely a
place of respect lose you in and then
when you're talking about like get like
a little bit of um like a gift for
what was it like the for his his nieces
yeah like I feel like you're showing
that you want to be integrated into his
family it's showing intention yeah and
and that's that's all that people are
trying to see now
okay so I have one more so this is
nine tips for taking care of your
husband taken from a 1950s home economic
book
have dinner ready plan ahead even the
night before to have a delicious meal on
time this is a way of letting him know
that you have been thinking about him
and are concerned about his needs most
men are hungry when they come home and
the prospect of a good meal are part of
the warm welcome needed amen how to be a
watch 101 yeah this means no and then
it's like the after it's the in modern
turns okay moms this means no last
minute Frozen nuggets chucked onto an
oven tray after the daycare is picked up
dinner needs to be thoughtfully planned
ahead of time and don't even think for a
second this isn't your job yes 100 too
prepare yourself take 15 minutes to rest
so you will look refreshed when he
arrives touch up your makeup put a
little ribbon on your hair and be fresh
looking he has just been with a lot of
work weary people be a little gay and a
little more interesting his boring day
may need a lisp lit lift wipe that I so
over it Mom face right off the second he
doesn't want to see that he's weary he's
tired and I think they're trying to be
sarcastic but I feel like this is
speaking facts he's weary he's tired you
are not and no you didn't have a day at
work either just tell the kids that you
need 15 minutes of me time to go get
ready for Daddy's arrival of course
he'll understand oh and don't forget to
change out that out of that top smells
of spew oh you see they're trying to be
sarcastic but I feel like it's facts
this is 1950s
yeah well it's like the the first half
is like the from the 50s and then like
it's the response of modern woman today
basically I think
um listen I think if you if your Mrs is
at home
doing all of those things
that it that is work it you know it's
not that's not light it's not easy right
you know that is something to be
respected and valued yeah I'd say a 10
minute touch up is not that deep though
yeah I mean I mean I'm not yeah okay
what but but still it's it's an effort
she's she's making an effort to look
after herself so that you can come in
and receive this you know this this
effort that she's made but not not only
that but the other things you know don't
just throw chicken wings in the in the
oven but actually plan the meal prepare
the meal someone else was talking uh
earlier on on the Pod about
um having a nice clean house to come
back to so if she's doing all of those
that's work that is that is you know
what the difference is though at the
time of at the time when women were at
home
and they weren't in the workforce they
were getting compensated by men
providing for everything yeah exactly
and obviously now that women are in the
workforce
they want men to provide the same way
but they're working yeah but it's the
lifestyle a lot of times women want like
a guy can pay for an apartment
exactly it's true
um okay so the number three clear away
the Clutter make one last trip through
the main part of the house just before
your husband arrives Gathering up school
books toys paper then run a dust cloth
over the tables your husband will feel
he has reached a Haven of Rest and order
and it will give you a lift too now this
is the response from the Modern Woman
yes a Haven of Rest and order do not
lose your [__] at him for fidgeting
flinging his shoes off in the middle of
the living room again right after you've
decluttered and yelled at the kids for
never cleaning up their toys again and
this is your job do it without complaint
what okay first of all your husband your
husband leaving the shoes on the floor
is not the same as your kids leaving
around toys okay this is like the leader
of your household in the provider uh can
you can you what did she say again
um
do not lose your [__] at him for
flinging his shoes off in the middle of
the living room again right after you've
decluttered and yelled the kids for
never cleaning up their toys again this
is your job do it without complaining no
no I got it I got it because this is the
thing like it's about perspective I get
women get frustrated but if your man was
to die tomorrow you'd be like damn I
wish he could throw his shoes in the
living room floor one more time like be
grateful uh you know like I left I left
my my house for four weeks I came back
and it was messy and I thought it was
gonna be mad because that's what you see
everywhere on TV and I was like oh my
goodness I'm essential he needs me
that's a good attitude to have yes it
really is if only every woman saw it
like that
I get to pick up your shoes yeah I know
I get excited and you know to be real
though if it's like an hour before your
man is coming home I'm a house if I
don't have any kids yet but you know the
hour beforehand you do kind of naturally
go around the house and try to pick up
some things so he doesn't come home to
hell I don't get it this is such a
standard basic thing it just should be
the base should be the minimum but I
don't I don't work though so it's like
different yeah that's what I was about
to say that's where it's not working
that should be the bare minimum but
that's like the shift so you've got some
people wanting that the female amount to
earn the money but at the same time
wants the female to do all the cooking
and all the cleaning no I think that's
weird I think it's only
it's only the
um a
egypti's also not working so if you're
doing everything then I think it is
absolutely 100 her duty to do everything
at home clean
if she's also working I personally don't
have anything to say on that because I
just wouldn't be interested in that so
in that case I would want the situation
to be where she's taking care of the
house entirely on her own I come home to
just absolute peace and Clarity but I
don't I don't know what it would be like
if she was also working because then
it's just like yes it was automated
nowadays it's not like you don't have to
spend three hours on a meal like you
used to when you say it like you're
gonna churn butter like stop it
it's not that and and the thing is guys
have to fix [__] around the house if
something breaks who fixes it when you
say it like guys guys have different
roles and our shit's all automated
washing machine
yeah dishwasher like the woman who wants
to work even though like financially she
could stay home and take care of her
kids because some women are only netting
like 500 a month like when you subtract
child care so it's like I think a lot of
times women are conditioned to be
workers and they they choose to take the
L they don't know that it's an L but
they're they're making that option yeah
but also it's about having the option as
well I think that sometimes when we say
oh like we'd love to be in a position
where you don't have to work they take
it as like oh I have to be at home or
you can have to be barefoot and pregnant
this is no what do you like the options
I think the women that push back on that
subconscious you don't want men to be in
control yeah yes yeah and that comes
down to trust that yeah a lot of it
comes down to trust as well
four prepare the children take a few
minutes to wash the children's hands and
faces if they are small comb their hair
and if necessary change their clothes
they are little treasures and he would
like to see them playing the part now
this is the response from the Modern
Woman yes do rummage through the washing
baskets and find clean clothes for your
little Treasures who have morphed into
monsters coming Witching Hour which is
right about the time he's due home and
resists leaving them grubby until bath
time he is not going to appreciate that
look at how miserable they are
misery and I'm like why why are the
clean clothes in the basket that's my
that was my thought of myself
zero organizations everything everything
that sounds like a chore to them to more
than women it's not much it's like more
than women don't want to be mothers like
no I agree and they feel like they're I
mean I don't I think they're just
ignorant it's not like your kids don't
have access to the internet all these
angry moms on Tick Tock they're gonna
make them feel like crap if they realize
how much you resent them but I think
that Sometimes women only think about
themselves but I think you know clean
the kids if you can all right like you
know they're little sometimes they get
into stuff just get a wet wiper to clean
it yeah
and you can't it's not it's not it's not
sexy you know I'd rather be taking Snaps
on for insta right now or in a bikini
doing some twerking videos right now
that's the thing that's I'm missing out
on doing that my friends are doing it
everyone else is doing it I don't want
to be looking after my kids and wiping
their faces in Dubai that's not sexy man
I want to be yeah I want to be on that
boat do you know what to be to be fair
to women yeah being a traditional
housewife and working at the same time
is difficult and I think as men like men
know how difficult it is to be a
traditional woman which men genuinely
want men generally want their women to
still have Traditional Values but when
women are presenting this boss [__]
it's in conflict with you being a
functional mother and wife
stay away from me
minimize all nor minimize all noise at
the time of his or his or I can't talk
at the time of his arrival eliminate all
noise of washer dryer dishwasher or
vacuum try to encourage the children to
be quiet be happy to see him greet him
with a warm smile and be glad to see him
now this is the response don't forget to
give the kids this memo oh and flicking
on the Telly for a bit of shush isn't
encouraged what if the PAW Patrol theme
songs annoy him just ask the kids to be
quiet and still easy I mean I don't
agree with the modern woman take no but
but I am going to say like I think
that's OD like I don't think my husband
cares if the dishwasher's on if the
washer dries he's not that kind of guy I
just feel like he wouldn't care like
what type of man you know it's gonna be
like actually babe all the machines got
to be off that's a specific kind of guy
I think this is in response to 1950s
back then those machines were very loud
okay yeah so that's why he's talking
about obviously today everything's
silent yeah the message is he wants to
just come home to it silent home nice is
that what you were saying yes outside is
the case we want to come home
I don't think a washing machine being
noisy at home is is chaos what you see
when when men hear chaos it's just like
arguing like I don't think yeah I don't
think a man if a man seen his clothes
getting washing the machine and it's
making a bit of noise I don't think a
man's complaining I don't think you've
heard those 1950 machines and I think
three of them are going up at once if
three of them are going off at once it
sounds like a warzer and I'm sure as
well back in the 1950s a lot of the jobs
were manual noisy laborious so coming
home to a place where it's a bit just
clean because it's a cool Serena I I
understand it but now it's it's not
really a problem half the machines I
probably don't even know it's on yeah
literally you can get like silent
machines
washing machines now yeah and I guess if
she is a housewife and she's been at
home all day she could do that stuff
before so you have free time together
when you get back as well some don't
number six so it's gonna tell us what
not to do don't greet him with problems
or complaints don't complain if he's
late for dinner count this as a minor
compared with what he might have gone
through that day
now this is the response yes yes to not
annoy him with stories of how you
juggled two little ones with gastro
today while also having to work from
home because they couldn't go to daycare
oh and now you can also feel your tummy
starting to growl again he doesn't want
to hear it
I think this entire article is women
complaining about being married to men
that aren't that fast work for them to
stay home no no I think it's like not
every guy can afford for you to stay
home so like you're going to have to
work Point Blank period at the end so
this whole this entire article I'm like
baby girl you better compete for the
high value band yeah you better compete
do something I don't know it's like
Deborah lose the 50 pounds
you know this girl's not skinny you know
I don't even know what she looks like
okay seven make him feel comfortable
have him lean back in a comfortable
chair or suggest he lie down in the
bedroom have a cool or warm drink ready
for him and arrange his pillow and offer
to take off his shoes speak in a low
soft soothe and pleasant voice allow him
to relax and unwind
response sounds like a dream
moms this means no shouting mom rage
even if there's no one listening to you
and your man is looking at his phone
instead of the full-blown sibling fight
that is happening before his very eyes
no just keep him call calm allow him to
relax you don't need a drink he does
is this very aggressive like she's just
they come across like no I am on
violence
silence button activate like you know
some of the girl that took off my man's
shoes yeah he must be mad
take off take these other shoes yeah
would you would you guys like that if a
girl said sit down I'll take your shoes
off yes please differently so feminine
to do that as well remember you're
coming to America are you gonna do that
no I tried it so he's just not into that
like he's right he wants to I've offered
he wants to take off his own boots but
to be honest so they're military boots
so they don't really smell the best so
I'm glad he was like no thank you no
thank you
um eight
listen to him
you may have a lot of things to tell him
but the moment of his arrival is not
that time let him talk first
oh shut up all right again he doesn't
care about your day or that your boss is
a jerk or that his baby needs a change
right now you've got risotto on the
stove that needs stirring or that his
pride and joy firstborn dropping the
F-bomb at preschool today just zip it
Zip Zip Scrolls a lot of preschool he's
already dropping that I think this is
peach mom from Twitter I don't know if
you guys remember that this lady went
viral for making cartoons about how much
he resents her husband but she doesn't
think that they're offensive cartoons at
all at all
now last one make the evening his
never complain if he does not take you
out to dinner or other places of
entertainment Instead try to understand
his world of strain and pressure he
needs to come home and relax
response yep we've got it he's had a
hard day his Barista Coffee that he got
to drink without having to microwave 10
times over and didn't have the Two
Sugars he asked for and when he got into
the office kitchen that was out of sugar
he didn't have the time to he didn't
take time he didn't have time to return
to the cafe because someone in the
office had a birthday that he had to
stay out and eat cake
so very specific this one okay so so now
she is apparently married to a high
value man and still complaining I guess
whatever author was inspired by this but
you know what it is this is interesting
it's because like women don't want men
who make the same amount of money or
less than them right so he goes and he
earns more and that probably means that
he has like a higher demanding job than
you and so it would make sense that he
might incurb more stress and then want
more peace at home but then they're
they're still complaining but they won't
date like the broke guy so I'm just I
don't think women really know what they
want I don't know I think women will
always find something to complain about
yeah yeah
they will actually go out of their way
to find something to complain about
because if everything's going well then
they start to like what's going on why
is everything going well something's
wrong right now so what do you guys
think of the dating advice from the
1950s how'd it sound some of it had some
really key valuable points which I think
some Modern women if they took half of
this they'd be able to get a man should
we implement this in wife's school oh
yeah if you did that people would be
getting married it'll be like how long
can we keep quiet
do it that'd be a good episode I mean
that'd be hard for a meeting we need to
start selling toys when to play with
like fidgeting toys so they can just
keep quiet
learn to read again the last name yes
how long can you go without social media
to the last statement was the same the
guy never takes his wife out
no she doesn't complain when he doesn't
don't complain if he doesn't I'll ever
take you out
never complain if he does not take you
out to dinner or other places of
entertainment you don't need to complain
you can just ask hey honey I feel like I
haven't gone on a date in a while do you
think that's something we could do this
weekend you don't need to complain yeah
it's about I think the best about the
delivery as well so it's like the stuff
you're saying no if you come across in
like a feminine way and and you're
cooperating correctly and it's it's not
a thing respectful way the guy will
actually want to I can't even imagine
like you haven't taken me out on a date
in a while and honestly I just I don't
appreciate it I feel like I'm being
neglected this just sucks like I'd
responded I'm not going to as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible